c'est notre chronique sur le terrain
[Musique]
et nous recevons elena volochine bonjour
lna on est ravi que vous soyez avec nous
en plateau vous êtes notre
correspondante à moscou depuis dix ans
vous avez notamment couvert l'annexion
de la crimée en 2014 ce conflit depuis
ses débuts il y à 7 ans dans le donbass
vous étiez sur le terrain côté frontière
russe au moment où l'offensive russe a
été lancée en ukraine est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter ce que vous avez vu
comment ça s'est passé oui alors moi je
suis arrivé deux ou trois jours avant
l'annoncé de vladimir poutine j'étais
dans la région de rostov on observer
quelques mouvements de troupes mais
c'était pas massive parce que il faut
savoir que toute l'armée russe étaient
déjà concentrés dans les républiques
séparatistes autoproclamé de donetsk de
lougansk y soit disant d'après la
version officielle russe était autonome
voulait se séparer de l'ukraine externe
mais en réalité qui était administrée
par la russie donc depuis 2014 et le
début de ce conflit il y avait déjà une
concentration de troupes à cet endroit
donc tout ce qui est arrivé ensuite côté
russe c'était du renfort pour lancer
cette offensive je suis remonté plus au
nord dans la région de belgorod c'est de
l'autre côté de la frontière et de la
seconde ville ukrainienne de kharkiv on
le voit aujourd'hui qui est pilonnée et
là c'est un nouveau front qui allait
s'ouvrir j'avais cette information de
source paramilitaire comme quoi il y
aurait une attaque de ce côté là et donc
effectivement là c'était beaucoup plus
massif en termes de concentration
militaire et au milieu de la nuit enfin
au petit matin en tout cas je reçois
l'appel de france 24 qui me réveille qui
me dit vladimir poutine s'allier à
lancer l'offensive et au même moment en
simultané j'entends parce que j'étais à
20 km de la frontière j'entends à ma
fenêtre les hélicoptères les premiers
obus et est en fait j'ai su après qu'il
était en train d'attaquer la frontière
mais j'ai eu la guerre ans qui a démarré
quasiment sous mes sauts sous mes yeux
en même temps que vladimir poutine alors
celle-là non c'était extrêmement
coordonnées c'était subi soudain et
c'était vraiment voilà l'annoncent et
l'attaquent est-ce qu'on s'attendait à
une attaque d'une telle ampleur et puis
finalement à différents points comme
comme ce qui s'est passé non vraiment
pas d'abord on pensait qu'il aurait et
mes sources me disais qu'il y aurait
plus une escalade parce que comme la
russie sont narratif officiel c'est de
dire qu'elle n'attaque pas on
s'attendait pas à ce qu'il y ait
vraiment une attaque aussi formel aussi
assumer aussi frontale puisque encore
une fois depuis le début depuis 2014
meilleure poutine disait je ne participe
pas à cette guerre donc là il la
déclaration est l' attaque et on
s'attendait à ce que ce soit peut-être
qu'ils iraient jusqu'au dniepr c'est à
dire qu'il couperait l'ukraine en deux
mais attaquer au sud jusqu'à kiev en
fait un est vraiment tout le territoire
comme ça avec ces chasseurs qui passait
dans le ciel que j'entendais passer dans
le ciel russes en allant vers l'ukraine
s'est tant que c'est cette entrée cette
attaque de la frontière cette entrée par
par tous les points c'est à dire côté
bélarus vers kiev côté mer d'azov vers
marioupol côté nord vers kharkiv est
aussi à l'ouest vraiment c'est d'une
telle ampleur c'était complètement
inédit vous avez des informations
peut-être sur sept ce convoi dont on
parle depuis plusieurs jours il fait une
soixantaine de kilomètres on nous dit qu
apparemment il sera ralenti pour
l'instant il y aurait peut-être des
problèmes
d'approvisionnement est ce que vous en
savez un petit peu plus sur ce qui se
passe concernant ce convoi alors ce qui
se passe à l'instant t non mais en tout
cas l'hypothèse la plus probable c'est
qu'il sait c'est évident pour tout le
monde ils vont essayer de prendre
quelques mois j'ai observé dans la
région de belgorod un des convois
incessants qui entraient par cette
frontière qui a donc été éventré qui a
été abandonné par les ukrainiens donc
c'est une voix libre d'accès donc hélas
c'était pendant tous les jours pendant
quasiment la semaine où j'étais là
c'était en continu un flot de tanks
d'artillerie en fait toute la force
armée de la fédération de russie depuis
l'extrême orient jusqu'en sibérie et
jusqu'à ses frontières étaient
concentrés pour aller en ukraine donc ce
qui se passe là très probablement c'est
que ils sont en train d'aller vers kiev
pour lise un petit peu dans le journal
pour employer cette méthode du siège qui
a qui a été employé à grozny qui a été
employé même dans ce conflit ukrainien
localement on en a pas beaucoup parlé
mais des balles cv îlots avec ces
débiles qui ont été encerclés assiégés
et pilonnés est prise par soi disant les
séparatistes mais en réalité par l'armée
russe en 2015 et donc même si ça paraît
improbable est incroyable parce qu'il
s'agit de quand même de kiev un lieu
historique la capitale maire de l'empiré
russe et même de la russie
historiquement et bien il y aura sans
doute ce siège et cette attaque en de la
capitale cela faisait plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois qu'on évoquait
cette offensive est ce que les
populations côté russe s'y étaient
préparés alors absolument pas et non
seulement la population à travers toute
la russie n'était pas prête mais surtout
à la frontière c'est à dire que ce matin
là où je suis descendu à la réception
j'ai réveillé la réceptionniste pour lui
dire la guerre a commencé elle m'a
regardé avec des grands yeux elle ne
comprenait pas de quoi je parlais et là
à 20 kilomètres de la frontière donc
c'est pour comprendre que en russie même
si on est dans une société ultra
militarisé où la guerre est présente en
permanence où les jours de fête les
enfants sont habillés en treillis et
porte des kalachnikovs pour faire comme
leurs grands parents qui ont vaincu les
nazis durant la seconde guerre mondiale
la gale la rhétorique militariste et
triomphalistes du bon rôle de la russie
extrêmement présente en russie et malgré
cela la russie n'était pas et les russes
n'étaient pas préparés à ce que leur
pays entre en guerre et on peut dire
même que jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'y a pas assez
de conscience du fait que la russie est
en train en guerre et attaquer le pays
voisin on le disait vladimir poutine
parle d'une opération spéciale militaire
de pour amener la paix ces différentes
rhétoriques selon différents moments et
différents officiels et différents
médias qui est utilisé mais le message
mais le message en gros c'est ça c'est
la russie est en train de mener une
opération de paix en ukraine et beaucoup
de gens même si ça paraît incroyable vu
de l'extérieur beaucoup de gens y
croient cette propagande elle n'est pas
nouvelle elle est active depuis le début
du conflit en 2014 une quelles sont les
conséquences sur la façon dont les
russes soit ce qui se passe justement
aujourd'hui par rapport à cette guerre
mais les conséquences et une réécriture
de l'histoire moderne c'est à dire que
là on n'arrive pas à écrire l'histoire
des crimes staliniens c'est pas étonnant
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'histoire moderne
celle qui se déroule sous nos yeux on
est absolument très très loin en russie
de de comprendre ce qui se passe est
donc encore une fois les russes sont
dans cette danse est dans cette danse
est dans ce va comme dans cet espace où
l'on dit que effectivement la russie ne
fait que se défendre et ça va pas aller
en s'arrangeant parce que
le chant informationnel est en train
d'être nettoyées et les messages sont en
train d'être d'être nettoyé vous le
disais à l'instant dans le sujet on n'a
plus le droit d'employer le mot guerre
on n'a pas le droit de citer d'autres
sources que les sources russes il ya des
rumeurs sur une possible loi martiale
qui va être qui va être mise en place
donc c'est clairement là il ya une
volonté de décrire une autre histoire
les quelques médias encore indépendants
ont été obligés de fermer sous la menace
du kremlin il ya la radio indépendante
russe qui a annoncé ce matin echo de
moscou figurines historiques art du
paysage médiatique russe qui a annoncé
son auto dissolution
ça veut dire que même finalement les
voiles et quelques voix indépendantes
qui restaient en russie pour informer
les gens qui essayent de voir un petit
peu plus loin et bien tout ça c'est en
train aussi de voler en éclats oui
complètement et puis vont probablement
aussi fermé wikipédia il y aura enfin il
y aura haro sur l'internet
déjà il ya pas beaucoup de gens qui
allaient chercher aussi des sources
d'information indépendant il ya beaucoup
de gens qui regardent la télévision mais
pour cela effectivement c'est en train
de se de ceux de se fermer il ya aussi
la situation des correspondants de
presse étrangers parce que nous
finalement on était un petit peu le
dernier bastion on travaille est
relativement librement malgré les
difficultés de terrain mais on n'avait
pas de censure c'est à dire que nous ton
qu'on était à créditer on pouvait
travailler faire le travail à raconter
ce qui se passe est là maintenant
comment çà et là maintenant ils sont en
train de durcir toutes les lois
liberticides
en ce qui concerne la liberté
d'expression par exemple la loi sur les
faits que muse qui a été à bord adoptez
disons le pour le coc vide pour pas
qu'on dise que la russie était en échec
face à lille contre le coc vie de cette
loi là est en train d'être durci et
maintenant on risque 15 ans de prison
pour les faits que nous qui concerne les
opérations militaires donc ça veut dire
qu'en fait ça prête à interprétations
n'importe quel message qui peut aller
qui peut déplaire au gouvernement peut
être passible de 15 ans de prison il y a
aussi la la loi sur la un décret sur la
trahison d'état pour les russes qui
travaille pour pour les organisations
internationales ça aussi ça peut être
interprété contre la presse la loi sur
le secret d'état elle depuis très
longtemps elle elle interdit jusqu'à
même si vous employer le mot armées
russes dans une publication c'est
tellement vague que vous êtes
potentiellement en train de dévoiler un
secret d'état sur telle position de
l'armée ou et c'est donc en fait tout ce
qu'on fait tous confine tout ce qu'on
dit peut être utilisé contre nous vous
êtes concrètement vous êtes
continuellement surveiller
jusque là bras tout ce que vous dites
alors jusqu'à présent on vous a vu une
certaine liberté jusqu'à maintenant
jusqu'à présent on pouvait travailler on
pense qu'on lit nos publications qu'on
regarde ce qui se passe vous êtes
surveillés et on va la laisser
travailler je pense que là ça va et ça
va crescendo et de jour en jour et
d'heure en heure la situation est en
train de s'empirer et tout le monde en
train de se demander est ce qu'on va
pouvoir réussir à travailler est ce
qu'on peut voir rester dans le pays
quitter le pays parce que les frontières
vont être fermés déjà les vols ont été
suspendus à destination de l'europe est
ce que cette loi martiale va être
adoptée ou pas comment elle va être
appliquée mais mais mais ce qui est
certain c'est que la halle a réussi à
vraiment en train de se refermer
complètement de se mettre en état de
forteresse assiégée réellement
physiquement alors que cet état d'esprit
de forteresse assiégée il est là depuis
des années et puis là on voit la chose
cependant plastiquement en fait ouais on
vous qu'est-ce que ça dure qu'est-ce que
ça augure
c'est difficile dans la situation se
trouve pas ce que ça va tellement vite
mais je pense que c'est une fermeture
juste totale
complète est un isolement absolu de
vis-à-vis de l'étranger du moins de
l'occident maintenant est-ce que ça va
durer ou est-ce que ça va être juste une
période de transition est ce qu il va
aussi y avoir une escalade est ce que
vladimir poutine a pour projet
uniquement l'ukraine ça aussi c'est une
question est ce qu'il y aura une réponse
occidentale militaire est ce qu'il y
aura de nouvelles entrées dans l'otan
comme comme comme le présage la finlande
et la suède il a mis ses forces
nucléaires en ordre de bataille je veux
dire tous les scénarios actuellement
sont ouverts sont possibles et la
situation échappe même à toute analyse
rationnelle par rapport à la vitesse où
ça va ya ce qui est en train de se
passer merci beaucoup merci mille fois
les mains d'avoir été avec nous et
d'avoir témoigné de tout ce que vous
avez pu voir ces dernières
ces dernières semaines ces dernières
heures tout ce qui s'est passé on est
content de pouvoir parmi nous à paris
merci est resté avec nous à
l'information